Focus
okay
[Music]
um the traffic is really badly for
anybody it was the only around when I
was traveling up and that was you know
three o'clock
[Music]
seven times committee
[Music]
uh
good morning
my safety advice
[Music]
so
[Music]
six times
before
which I haven't done a microphone
okay
so imagine this is the first started
Commission of this meeting this Premiere
um welcome to immunotherapy
healthy appreciate myself
[Music]
um
here we are so um
foreign
Democratic services
Council David Jones councilman
thank you
thank you for that moving on to the
German garage
San Francisco
do you have any other questions
please not received apologies but a note
say Dr Carr
isn't isn't presence
and councilor Mercer and councilman new
this is
moving on to the minutes
2052 and I would happy to go to a
presence yes
thank you
okay
foreign
[Music]
appendix 2.
3 that all members will be Consulting on
possible options regarding the registry
numbers addresses
now this is the response to a number of
concerns being raised by members in
relationship communication and Justice
and Declaration of register
these convergence consists of adoption
we have the subject of the daily unless
I read a book to representative of the
time where the people who have concerned
nursing home
um currently it's normal about the
number of concern and the motion of it
it's inside on a case-by-case basis
this one's not much the executive on the
Transporters January it was noted I'm
unagreed the Constitution
Army consult service options that were
very forward which are outlined in
reports
Richmond
traffic
[Music]
and then applies Sensations
of the committee of the sun's equipment
right now 2017
unfortunately to apply a blanket policy
but where my own members addresses and
there's enough of course creates the
sensitive interest and not made public
available
um we're all seeing the results
and concept reports and selectively
misidentified and support the council
products taking its implicit variation
of the information received through the
constipation
blood pressure Comics shows to hold
their effects results
but for those that did 71 percent of
this continent found the public
available Justice compromised there on a
farmers safely
[Music]
members
[Music]
that's right
[Music]
generally hear me
um
[Music]
[Music]
all right
anyway
China
because
um it's about experience of this kind of
issue is
it is
aggressive tendencies and members will
probably be what's uncommon and people
don't get their own way there is also a
Hospitality that people will seek to
take that back from the person that
think one is responsible and in some
ways
um I think the way things are currently
arranged as it says in the reports are
exactly the way that they're
Arrangements
that I've worked for
and
[Music]
that message is hardly something that's
within your leader to suggest
there will be people out there from my
experience who will think that that is
in some way behaving the secretive
Manner and therefore your counsel is not
then they are accountable because
they're you know withdraw themselves
from access to the public but obviously
you are still accessible through your
email addresses which will be included
etc etc
um I I can't advise you more money
to support you to debate and consider on
the practice of the issues that are
before you
[Music]
um
participation in the survey is probably
a little bit disappointing I I don't
know if it's Alexander's report when the
survey is conducted free or post the
election
um
happens
[Music]
um and why don't you answer any
questions that are honest with this I
would say that I have personally always
adopted a defend the liberal approach to
um withholding information when I had
been requested you said by councilors
and have not insisted as anyone because
my colleagues were on saying that unless
you've got a police reports
think about taking the recruits away and
believe that there are some
entrepreneurs
and having said that just as simple I
don't really like my address
if you decide to go down the route of
saying that everybody's address is
and that's sort of flying slightly at
the face of the way the legislation is
drafted but as gems already outlined the
the cspl in the 2017 records have
recommended that there is there is a
more structured approach to removing
addresses so that you would be in line
with that writing press the legislation
yeah so I think we'll be we'll be back
up to the debate on the floor there
would be emotional grips
not sure if this is working or not but
I'll just keep Landing
um I've got a question actually about
[Music]
um
like if you own the properties if it is
an asset so stay in the councilors you
rent property wouldn't have to put their
addresses
his address was yeah
is
members of the public might not
necessarily know you have an interest in
the third party property and were you to
for example make a planning application
and respect to that property there is no
accountability in terms of you seeking
to influence the decision-making process
through finding up some other process so
perhaps the rationale behind it that yes
tonight
[Music]
um
yeah I think um on the whole week in
Trafford is quite safe being counselor
and I don't think I've really
experienced how much intimidation and
stuff but I've heard stories from other
people that they have which is really
worrying and it's only one incident is
one to remaining in my book but
if I speak to family members they are
quite shocked they're exactly because
also Beyond on the website it's got to
be very interested the same as my
address so that they would they would
feel slightly worried about it
um so that makes me worry because I just
wonder if people wanting to be a
counselor
if they knew that they dressed between
you'd probably be made available whether
it was kind of make them sink again
about whether they wanted their cancer
and that kind of worried me also because
we need a diverse range of cat
counselors in this building to reflect
uh those people they might be blocked or
worried about becoming account so that
probably were immunity so um I came to
think not having enough objectives made
available
the
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
prescriptions
maybe not everybody
so some questions
about the representation referencing or
character derivative it's um
it's a little bit like the uh sort of
diagrams I did in the second world war
if the airplanes that came back and
they've got all the bullet holes on the
diagram and said right we'll reinforce
those parts of the claim it made
absolutely no difference because you
need to see the planes that didn't make
it back
um and that's where they actually got a
mathematician to look at it and
reinforce the bits where you don't have
anything
what we need to see here is we need a
survey of the people who actually have
decided not just um or not to stand in a
seat
that's almost impossible to do before
then I thought what's wrong
all of us who have members of the party
will
um actually have a choice of where we
stand our candidate so there's lots of
people in my party your party can say
well I'm not willing to go the whole way
but I understand somewhere I know when
and we're unlikely to Target we would
call this paper countless and we have
names for that so I've got people I've
got to your husband so I'll help you out
I'll Stand in a sequence not very
prosperous for us
um and uh thank you very much we know
that they're not rich with they wouldn't
be willing to stay under the seat but
they might be to win because they don't
want to for a variety of reasons maybe
this is one of the reasons so how can we
contact those well of course every year
they do typically come here provide all
their details they go to democratic
services and provide the knowledge
and we have their contact details
because this is pertinent to the very
nature of sounding we are able to use
those contact details here to say in
relation to something you've previously
done with us you gave a free email would
you consider this so if we don't I I
feel that we can move forward today but
if we feel we don't want to there is an
opportunity to reach out so all the
others who've stood in seats that didn't
win and say how do you feel and I
suspect you'd get that much different
sets of pie charts because you would
eliminate a lot of the response buyers
because at the end of the day
I was willing to do it yes I have
concerns and I've heard things and I've
got colleagues who have done this for 20
years 21 is corrected me the other day
so
um but at the end of the day I still
went through with it so I must have a
certain level of acceptance of what it's
like and we all was because we did but
there are all those who didn't we
haven't heard their voices so there is
an opportunity there thank you and I
just clarify something I may be wrong
here
I'm pretty sure that having your address
on the nomination paper is optional
correct me again
[Music]
sorry does this this relates to the
register
that test which really somebody
why would somebody want to check my my
register of interest I'm very boring
in the same house for nearly 40 years I
don't have any business interests or
anything like that so
it's not that easy to find dagger on the
council or both page it's a couple of
clicks fair enough but why would you
want to know where I live
and that's where the elements I I've
never thought about this until a couple
of years ago when my son who is
obviously also a counselor has
says have a lot of rather Savory flux
over the years so in order to protect me
because we share it a survey and he
might be terrific register as well
because of the nature of perspects we
was getting
that goes with the job unfortunately
that we build support I I've never
thought about it until what happened
and it did kind of I think it depends on
the situation you're in at home
and I was on there and I'm getting on
the news so yeah perhaps it does make me
a bit more vulnerable I didn't think
about it 10 years ago when I was first
enacted so
maybe some group challenges if you
haven't disgruntled messages
very angry about something that will
happen done yeah
[Music]
particularly if you've got your children
in the house or whatever and yeah it can
be
I think that's the problem 10 years ago
in a very different world
kinds of change
of my council's addresses should be
probably available and a couple of
clicks is all it takes I'm a determined
person will do that
personally I've been in favor of the
blanket button
I was very very
I actually have my I gave my address I
was asked for it and I didn't think I
gave it but it was published and it was
on the list of when people when people
clocked into the computer to check the
name of your counselors the address was
there
and I got a number of people who
disappeared on my doorstep around my
doorbell wanted to know answers and if
it did that to me and they wasn't
threatened me anything like that
and then it was my daughter who got
really upset I was on my own at the time
my husband was working before but she
said Mommy it's not safe and more not to
worry about than for what I felt I asked
for my address to be withdrawn of the
council address
but instead of mine but if you think
about it if anybody wants to contact the
council if they look through the south
of council I will send a a text or or at
the time it was letters comparison or
anything like that we are contextable we
don't have to be contacted even without
our own addresses
we are available and available straight
away we all publish telephone number
so as long as I think enough Avenues are
made for members of the public to
contact us in other words telephone
through the council and so on the circle
that I in my opinion I think there's no
necessity for our home address
absolutely
for me the test would be this cannot be
a device to avoid people contacting you
with you therefore turn that down if
anybody who needs to contact you can
yeah
because not everybody has as electronic
devices so if there needs to be if you
like the old-fashioned methods of
contact as well providing you can all be
contacted fairly imaginable then I
suggested
four options I really are over there but
as long as it's not used as a device to
block the medicinal contact
so I think I'm agreeing with you yeah
I think it has a job yeah I mean I I
would have sort of sort of check to go
out and say from the uh
episode of series of vocals at the start
of the year
Council
and he made the series
Almost daily basis
which I didn't actually try and assist
you with it and then
stayed where you stopped but he was
he was quite threatening actually and I
didn't think you need to look at my
address
so when I was at the time when this
report was done
and so on so I think
I think perhaps the default should be
that we don't give our addresses
so but I do think if somebody
like the system they want to be able to
address and maybe that should be sort of
a reverse of number two
but but three three number three
recommendation three deceptions
I mean the only thing on the um
Declaration of Interest I think
it's understandable because it's all
about property and being you know like
opening times
and
or whatever it is
but I think
especially has already been said
the last few years but I think
particularly since the pandemic as well
I think people's attitudes are really
dark okay
and so some of you know I do have quite
a few questions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
but
I think having your address
we've made that Declaration of our own
of interest to the council and that will
be taken on board and it's all recorded
so the information is there
um but why should it be so accessible to
people
yes the question that Denise was saying
is
it why would somebody goes to that much
trouble
to have the Drone
yeah I agree with everything that
councilor Jones just said I just wanted
to touch upon when you can education and
it accounts does go forward with the
planning application their address will
be published in that application anyway
so I can't see the reason directly
between the Declaration of interests
address will be published in that part
of the planning process that you can't
avoid
I I appreciate that people want to speak
yeah can I just answer that that point
that is impressive transparency argument
and and of course everybody's address is
printed on the corner of their planning
application what the members of the
public would not be able to do if you
have your addresses withdrawn from the
Declaration it's cross-reference now to
find out that you're being honest enough
to say that's a funding application I'm
putting that in it's my own account so
I'm going to have an apartment
you haven't got the checks and balances
in place I'm not advocacy against it I'm
just saying that's the reason why a
member of the public would be able to
say
you've got a planning application in
this and you're and I'm going to say
this it's an only one around this route
would do it but I've come across it
myself then it starts on the committee
yeah just a quick one to say that Going
Back to Basics and I think prevention is
always better than detection
the detection phase of it it means that
something is very randomly gone wrong
prevention is the opportunity that
you're discussing and the outcomes that
if you don't prevent that potential
crime are so severe as we've heard from
a number of people that Society is
changing that it surely must be that the
prevention should be the first and best
method of dealing with this
yeah just thinking and
where we are in the sort of ways that we
live
we've got an opportunity next May
when it's all answer actions to put
something packed in the induction pack
or mention something
you know you get a pack don't you but
when you if you're successful maybe it's
something in there so that we know from
F will all be new to an extent won't be
hopefully
um if something in that pack gives you
the option at that point
to either depending on what we decide to
either have the blankets no it's not on
the register of Interest or if you
actually have it added it
um
but of course
um if it's those sort of helpful for us
then mum's got my address
you won't be able to see in the register
of interest that I own it but we will
never know the council
because
it was elected so you still know that I
have put an application in so you don't
necessarily know that's my address but I
have an interest in it because I've got
the application so if you could look at
it the other ways
so how do you know on account so it's
public knowledge because it's public
election so I'm not sure a Clarity
logically
an example of all the leader of the
council that I was working at previously
at only five or six properties
it's not quite so easy to identify him
as a counselor
whereas a member of the public knowing
his address and knowing that one of
those applications
or multiple addresses
people going through the planning
application agenda identifying the
properties that are on there just out of
interest to see who's putting in
applications for what
if they haven't got the cross reference
to know that you're a counselor at that
point
there's an Evidence of crossover that's
not that's not there anymore that's all
I will say I'm not suggesting in any way
shape before it's a reason not to do
what you're thinking about doing I'm
just offering it as a one of the routes
that I know previously people have taken
to double check what council to do
[Music]
[Music]
Walk of Life where
home addresses are so readily available
so it's nice that we're scrutilizing
ourselves and our reasons behind it but
actually something if somebody mentioned
gdpr you know it's very very robust
piece of legislation
to be an example of how the problems our
information so I think where am I
normally and I think you know I'd be
very comfortable to
now
I used to hear that they were adorable
in the post office do they stayed all of
them or if they've been now
yeah
it was it used to be I've had to say
more about 20 years I don't know whether
it's still stands but he's being like
total drug and my hope of Photoshop
and it had all the address
[Music]
Korean
so and actually
it's just that I think it's about helps
and I thought we've been in it maybe a
week
because they wouldn't have been on it
anyway because it all just moved into
the house and it's just come to another
look forward if you still do that
because if it's still ongoing now then
obviously it's an original
you don't care
so so in removing that protection
they did it to other protection without
person identity
is
[Music]
consult electrical problem
but I think we've got this issue there
off too there's an edited role and a
full role
perhaps the solution here and of course
the advantage of coming to town hall is
we hear a few times to consult register
there's no lack of transparency here we
have the data removed from the website
so that all on Sunday
this will still be set for the final 63
pieces of paper and Democratic Services
if someone had a genuinely pressing
concern they can come to the term Hall
book the appointment speech reception go
to democratic services and we can see
they're official proper persons it will
actually yes
we can see a detail we then know who
that was they came to they go I've got
no idea
that perhaps is is
legislation but we're not having it on
the website forever or for the world to
see yet again
you've got emails you've got phone
members all sorts of social media so why
would they need to go around to the
house
yes at one point I I think we're getting
a little bit sidetracked why does
everybody need to know our address they
need to be able to contact us
but they need to be able to contact us
quickly now I also most of my emails or
when I try to within 24 hours I'm sure
most other Council was still the same so
if one of my residents wants to contact
me
all they have to do is send an Email
down to say oh I will bring me up
because my telephone number
published anywhere and wherever they're
accomplished since called psych about
and complications he sent us around it
simply the names of the councilors on
the
website Etc so they can contact you by
phone they can contact by email they
can't get us better and say I won't
speak to come
can you leave a message why do they need
to know the film address for any good
and valid reason
but this is what I don't understand they
need contact
they need to be able to get in touch
with accounts
yes
you know we better go through University
yeah
I'm not it's not stress it's wrong
and I'm not strongly against it but
there might be some people who might
want their address
and is that okay
um we're not we're not talking about the
publication of your contact address
we're talking about the publication of
property property owned on the register
of interests so my colleague longstone
Colony counts are very appreciated
seems to be
okay with that most of the time so this
might take the band would apply to
clever but that doesn't stop her
changing the address underneath her
little photo or the website we're not
talking to say I've given an address I
need to track a town hall apartment Road
she could keep her aggressive I don't
know if she still has anymore so if
people really wanted to when you're
asked for your address because we have
had this question raised there might be
a few who actively wanted them well you
can publish it where I've got Talbot
Road Town Hall
[Music]
so I think that's the solution to that
problem you have the blanket there and
the Declaration so your address is not
shown there because you own the rent
property whatever but if you're super
keen on the address bit instead of
putting care of telephone we could put I
think the practice provider that solves
that you know
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
against
the stations
context results
clean up
about
evacuation of Interest
can I can I just say that that's the
report says what we're talking about is
the population dependent addresses on
the published Declaration of Interest
pages
so but I think that's right I think I
think there's been totally human Liberty
about the need to give addresses
the requests of contact
um
because
it's not interested
[Music]
um
so I can talk for myself I'm sure I can
speak probably for every other Council
in the world actually our residents in
the main if they know us it's very easy
for them
[Music]
but if they were that desperate to find
the other dress
that they wanted to check from what
properties I owned or anything else like
that they would almost certainly already
and know the address
you know because they have to have a
reasonable
to me well in that we don't describe
people know them and I think if they're
sufficiently interested in your personal
in the counselors personal affairs it's
so much responding to know where they've
got their
interests of where their money is put on
all that sort of thing then I think they
might have reasons that perhaps
ought to be in their Liberation together
oh absolutely yeah
[Music]
just quickly chat I think it's right
that
um any other personal address which is
yeah we've agreed it won't be published
unless you specifically request that but
I do think that other business interests
should be disclosed and also yeah I have
to disclose the fact that I'm a member
of a trade Union is on you know
um so I think people need to know that
sort of information but knowing actually
so it's a reasonable
um
[Music]
moving on to
uh
yes just two things that I can just
briefly touch on those firstly and
anticipate let's go back to the item
you've just focused on we haven't left
the opinion notion from the local
government Association to indicate that
they are prepared to fund a fully funded
uh seminar with members on a topic of
our Tuesday unfortunately all they've
told us is there are four to these
topics that are available and they
haven't told you
but fully funded perhaps with me so yes
we'll have some of that and I have
written to them and said please
a couple of days ago but at least one of
the the subjects that we're talking
about is coping with intimidation for
counselors and open class so I think
probably the best thing I can do is to
make sure that
we circulate two members when I've got
all of the information about what 14
years is available are available and
then perhaps either trying to agree by
consensus on a course that's most
applicable to most members or if we
can't agree maybe put it on the next
agenda but I'm constantly not wanting to
necessarily wait that long because
I'm sure so it's reminding everyone's
all working on board with that that
might be helpful so I think that's
probably a bit of good news I don't know
whether that's going to particularly
teach anybody anything that's useful to
know
so that's that's what we want the other
is I suppose and I don't know what
you're going to be covering their Deputy
emotions report but I can just say so
far this year since I've been here
there's been two matters that have been
looked into neither of them have come
any further dismissed at the early
assessment stages that's really awesome
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
um
it attempted to be he says fully funded
the accommodation and the course itself
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and the issue came up about doing
casework
um in other people's wards
and when I started on the council
um I came into it knowing that if I
wanted to do casework outside of the
world after counseling
that you had to inform the counselors
first
and not one of the counselors on that
group knew it they thought it didn't
exist in the Constitution
and some of those counselors have been
here quite some time
but part five of The Constitution under
codes and protocols 11.7 says members
frequently exceed correspondence from
their award constituents and they're
asked to respond to and help with a
variety of issues and their rights which
is a fair
um there is an expectation that vendors
will deal with issues arising on their
own war that are often referred to them
by constituents again of the members
will not deal with issues that originate
from outside their Ward unless the
relevant board Council to unable to deal
with the issue the constituents
expressed the indicates that they do not
wish to be involved of all the counters
for the area
and which I think is a perfectly
reasonable request to a councilor but
11.8 said if any of those three reasons
to occur it's courtesy to still inform
the board counselors that you're taking
on the caseworker now that seems
completely fair to me because counselors
could undermine another Council in
another world by taking on casework
without telling them and I think
counselors sometimes have to work with
counselors from other Wars and they have
to work together and they should have a
relationship with respect and
understanding
um you know even if that's the different
parties might have robust conversations
from time to time so I was quite
surprised that so many councilors
weren't from whereas this
um and it did worry me quite a bit
because I think it's something that
every councilor should not because they
could start to get involved in matters
where they should really be speaking to
other councils about
so I don't know
yeah yeah quite comfortably but um
I just wondered if we need to remind
councilors about this each year
doesn't matter of course
um whether there should be dedicated
training for all new members
um around the Constitution and what's
expected
I think if we do this enough already so
that that could be a question to the
membership Development Group we can do
which trains the councilors but also
um if you do go to part five of The
Constitution it is a massively long
document and I think the code for the
council at the right of the clock and
you would expect this to be in that part
of
the constitution in top five
but actually difficult times
and when you're trying to search for it
it's really hard to find it institutions
I just wonder whether the Constitutional
working groups need to look at the
Constitution and maybe the protocol code
that's all in one place it's been easier
for them to access but they were just my
thoughts and I just thought I'd predict
to this committee
for the next research
University in the meantime
[Music]
I I I'm slightly disadvantaged because I
wasn't here because the last elections
but I'm assuming that there is a program
training for election with new members
after their elections because that's
what I would have been on the practice
yeah
um I think the quote you're taking is
from the member office approach to
qualify 19 part five
which is in place of your quite
Direction you've read it out by a
student from where it sits he doesn't
fall part of the code of conduct against
which members code would lead the
complaint to be made
I absolutely agree with you you would
expect if someone is asked to work in a
different Wars that they would have the
courtesy to notify the water councilors
of that award that they've been asked to
do with us and whether it's courtesy or
whether it's code to contact I think
people should be aware of it some of my
life certainly recognize
the question is I don't know what did
you want that to be brought forward
because I think it looked into maybe
with a working group could I ask you a
question because of the fact back from
that are you saying that if that is
without before these counselors together
[Music]
and again it could be something that
working group would look at with the
view to the next code of conduct
possibly be changed through it but at
the moment
but I'm not watering it down again so
it's it's it's something I would expect
councils to adhere to but it's different
from there's actually a code of conduct
complaintant
um
so it just has a curiosity does it
happen a loss then I think people
working
welcome thank you from next year because
we've got some boundary changes
I'm obviously coming to an election when
you've got boundaries that's that's a
whole different scenario that you would
expect you need to go to campaign in the
world that you're going to be standing
for elections people do confuse you know
obviously my board that crosses with
altering them acrosses with their risk
um
it is that potential confusion
foreign
food you know
um difficulties and I'm not sure if it's
something people do a lot or not so try
to think counselors
if you take an extra word I mean yeah
anyway so take an extra it seems a bit a
little bit strange
sometimes it's easier to just sort it
there and I'm going to go about several
years now but as an Excellency Hickory
much heart which is simply bored
broad piece is the opposite side of the
road there's been an incident where
people
basically smeared something rather nasty
on all the children's play equipment I
got an email at 6 30 7 o'clock in the
morning
got straight on to get the issue sorted
copied in to what would typically what
canceled and I have to say that it was
sorted out
before nine o'clock basically which you
know was super service from the council
but I wasn't going to start reading all
the councilors at seven o'clock in the
morning you know right around the
doorstep as it was so sometimes it's you
just have to write 40s almost cut
offices
well I think it's something
we don't tend to you know if we do get
an Australian piece of Facebook it was
um fairly often
aware of that but it is an accepted
practices
[Music]
is
going forward
[Music]
this is
um
[Music]